we thought there was good news it's
temporary right now the nation is
bracing for a rush at the border still
once title 42 ends the policy was set to
end tomorrow then Chief Justice John
Roberts stepped in temporarily putting
that on hold the Biden Administration
has until 5 PM Eastern today to file a
response the White House says it has
dispatched 23 thousand border patrol
agents and one thousand processing
coordinators to the southern border
while the Texas National Guard deployed
an additional 400 troops to El Paso
where border agents remain overwhelmed
by the number of people flooding into
America most of them
unvetted at this point
this is new video
showing a large group of people sleeping
on the ground at the city's airport
waiting for their flights
so we processed them and I put that in
quotes because our men and women are
overwhelmed and then they fan all over
the country
those are just the people that we know
about ice has actually lost track of 150
000 illegal immigrants and now they're
learning about more
and how that happened
well there are already a million of them
here
Fox new digital news digital rather just
obtained ice training videos from
November 21 to February 22 and they
revealed the agency was not able to keep
tabs on people because of the Biden
administration's relaxed no processing
immigration policy
operation Horizon the background on this
for you guys that may be new to it you
know over the summer we had well over
150 000 folks come in uh they were
issued a piece of paper that said go
find somebody in ice and
um
and that was pretty much it so there was
no processing I know this isn't
something that you guys asked for uh and
and I can assure you that no one in the
Criminal Alien program asked for it
either
well we like all the information we can
get just imagine how much worse it will
be of title 42 ends and the floodgates
are open and by the way if you start to
tell the truth about things being open
at the border the White House says that
you're helping the Smugglers and you're
against America imagine they hate the
truth imagine because as if the people
coming to this country are sitting
around watching cable news all day
they're not coming because we're talking
on cable they're coming because we're
letting them in Joe Biden has turned
this country into the college bar that
doesn't check ID do you remember when
you were a young kid and the word got
out that there was this one bar that
wasn't enforcing ID procedures so
everybody started showing up that's
where we are and there's like a real
callous indifference almost a
sociopathic indifference to the
suffering they're creating at the border
because number one it is a humanitarian
crisis when you talk about what's
happening to the women crossing the
border number two you talk about
fentanyl becoming the leading cause of
adult death in this country but number
three this completely undermines their
Public Health initiatives as it pertains
to covid I don't hear a word about
getting vaxxed and boosted and wearing a
mask if we're taking a covid screening
mechanism a disease screening mechanism
and we're throwing it to the side it
undermines everything they do and
Biden's shame on him won't even go to
the Border because they want to draw
attention to the crisis although in his
defense when they asked him to make a
run for the Border he did think they
meant Taco Bell and he was like Yeah Joe
won't let me have that so here we are ah
Tammy you know while there was a lot
there
he has no opinion
but part of the coveted argument that
you're making is so excellent because
that's still where we are we're being
told now you see areas that are
considering you know temporary mandated
lockdowns or or mask wearing I should
say more mask wearing than lockdowns at
this point but I mean we we still are in
some sort of an emergency with flu RSV
what are they calling it The Trident
yeah I mean we have a doctor on the
couch here yeah and there's some reports
that I'm sure Dr Nicole can speak to
this as well that in fact the flu season
is kind of average like what it was
before the pandemic it's not this
monster thing that has been reported but
beyond that it's not just kofit we we
had this issue before zika measles
tuberculosis the plague that there's a
whole host of other things but we're
most in danger as we were in the summer
and the fall of 2019 when we don't know
what's happening so we know these things
we're prepared for them we have tests we
know to look the issue becomes what
don't we know and that is just like we
didn't know about zika and that was it
was and is a horrible thing that now has
moved from South America up into America
affecting uh fetuses affecting children
deforming you know remember it affected
the head of the little babies it was
horrible things going on the plague is
out there it is I mean you know yeah it
always exists and we can we can deal
with it but that's what title 42 was for
and it's not just a surge that's going
to happen and it's happening in this
week that's been the incentive for
months and so it is this backup and the
build up and those thousand processors
which you talked about in your uh intro
are really just to process them there's
nothing that's going to be sent to stop
this so more of them will come Kennedy
and more of them will be allowed to stay
because they're bringing in processors
yeah so they have their big rubber
stamps that's exciting the Asylum
process takes about five years and those
are under good circumstances those are
under normal circumstances but the
numbers that we've seen are very
abnormal they're they're two and three
times higher than anything we've ever
seen so it's impossible even if you have
a third more processors than you had
before uh the entire system is
overwhelmed it is a massive failure of
government on every single level not
only the president who is gaslighting
and lying to anyone who will ask about
this and you know that's himself or
through his press secretary Karin jump
here but that's also the abdication of
responsibility from Congress and every
other branch of government that has just
washed their hands of this problem where
you have we saw yesterday 500 people
sleeping in a room that should take a
hundred that's right one bathroom so
they hate people they hate people who
are terrified and in pain and they're
doing nothing to help them except lying
and saying yeah the The Border's secure
and the president is working well and
then they try to cancel us if we tell
the truth about it I mean that's what
that is that that's furthering the
censorship that we see on the social
platform straight up do it they bring
bed bugs lice consumption and the vapors
so so Tammy it's interesting what you
were saying because title 42 did so much
more I want to get to Art Del Cueto last
hour on the Faulkner Focus let's watch
the border is pretty much wide open and
there seems to be no consequences for
individuals entering the United States
right now this Administration needs to
realize it's a problem not just for
their own political agenda but it's a
problem for every single American in
this country it's going to take this
government the administration to
actually start taking care of the people
actually put aside their hatred for the
last Administration and realize that
they're doing more harm to Americans
right now that's where I want to go with
you Dr Nicole Sapphire
um when you when you hate the last guy
enough to want to hurt the future of
America where are you well I want to go
back to what you started with talking
about what the press secretary said last
week and she said that anybody who is
saying there's chaos at the border or
there will be chaos with the removal of
title 42 or saying that the border is
open that you are essentially working
for Smugglers you are an agent of
misinformation what an important thing
to say and how disrespectful that is to
our border patrol to the civilians whose
lives have been upended because of the
failure of government and the chaos that
is happening at the border they have
zero respect for the American people and
their condescension is just so permeable
and you can just tangible it is it is
awful what is happening and with title
42 right now just about anyone other
than Mexicans can come in through our
border seeking Asylum whether they
really need Asylum or not if title 42 is
removed then everyone including the 2
million Mexicans who are denied entry
over the last two years
are then able to come the Democrats have
had complete governmental control for
the last two years they've done
absolutely nothing it is a crisis at the
border now and the Republicans
absolutely need to step up and do
something because it is a crisis at the
border all right I do want to get to
this because Democrats are starting to
speak out you know and and William heard
we know as a congressman from Texas
formerly he had a lot to say he was
tweeting this yesterday Obama deported
three million more folks than Trump he
didn't use title 42 the Biden
Administration can increase expedited
removals the fancy term for deporting
using existing actually it's title eight
he didn't get that right here uh by
authorities the tool isn't the issue
it's the acknowledgment of the crisis
and the will to enforce our laws title
eight Kennedy yes allows for so much
more in the lines of deportation you can
do it for for criminal activity I mean
it's a long list that's that was always
there so they could get away with 42 and
then reflexively go right to something
even more powerful do you think they'll
do it no they won't do it and they also
won't outline who they want in this
country and who they want to stay out of
this country and those are two very
important lists because we want people
here who are going to work hard add to
the economy make the country better we
don't want people who are going to
commit violent crimes who are engaged in
gang activity and who are going to
actively hurt people and make the
country worse and and you have to be
very clear about who you want and who
you don't I don't know how you do that
with these numbers last last thought
Jimmy well nope the K train is right I
mean there's this real indifference to
the well-being of everyone on every side
of this women coming into this country
are getting sexually assaulted about 30
of the time if they're coming in
illegally people on this side of the
Border are being killed but in their
instance the politics are always more
important than the people so they're not
worried about protecting humans they're
worried about protecting themselves
they're not missing children yeah we've
become a participant in the trafficking
of children who have now who are now
missing and will never be found in the
midst of this country and let me shame
on us we have a responsibility and to
her point about children the Democratic
party shut down the government over what
we called kids in cages under Trump okay
we have 10 times
the cages were built under Obama but
that's the point it's all garbage shame
on them hey everyone I'm Emily compagno
catch me and my co-host Harris Faulkner
and Kaylee mcaneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights